elle a dit quoi
faut sur ça me le 7 mars dernier au cœur
des Ardennes dans ce petit village d'une
cinquantaine d'habitants situés à l'Est
de la Belgique il y a une agitation
inhabituelle
policier juge d'instruction avocat et
substitut du procureur investissent les
lieux
ils ont un rendez-vous macabre
aujourd'hui a lieu la reconstitution
judiciaire du meurtre d'un homme très
apprécié dans le village Bruno libert
Nancy sa femme arrive
escorté par une inspectrice de police la
justice belge l'a fait sortir de prison
pour venir ici
si vous voulez nous faire une
déclaration pour
y est enfermée depuis 7 mois dans
l'attente de son procès elle revient
pour la première fois dans sa maison
depuis le meurtre
elle n'ose pas entrer
et elle craque
quelques minutes plus tard un autre
personnage clé de la faire fait son
apparition Fabienne une voisine très
proche du couple
que s'est-il passé dans ce salon le 11
mars 2015 ce soir-là Bruno Libert un
père de famille de 54 ans sans histoire
meurt chez lui d'une crise cardiaque
mais quelques mois plus tard une enquête
pour homicide va être ouverte par le
parquet de Liège il ne s'agirait plus
d'une banale disparition mais d'une
terrible machination pour faire
disparaître un homme
pourquoi sa femme se retrouve elle
aujourd'hui en prison
quel est le rôle de cette voisine si
proche du couple que leurs enfants
l'appelaient Tati
le crime était presque parfait
[Musique]
enfant du pays Bruno Libert a toujours
été fidèle à sa région natale
généreux et dévoué il s'implique dans la
vie de son village il devient même
sapeur-pompiers volontaire à la caserne
locale pendant près de 15 ans un homme
apprécié de tous
[Musique]
pierre Ness était son commandant à
l'époque et surtout son ami il se
souvient de Bruno un bricoleur de talent
[Musique]
il a vécu quelques années ici mais il
faut vous dire que ici il y avait rien
du tout et Bruno Libert a construit
cette maison de ses propres mains c'est
un gars qui avait des maires en or et
qui avait tout pour réussir dans la vie
et en plus comme il était pompier mais
il mettait je vais dire au service de la
population toutes ces qualités donc
quand on a les sur des incendies où il y
avait à refaire le toit mais c'était pas
le dernier
à monter sur le toit et a commencé à
remettre des tuiles à remettre des bars
etc c'est un gars qui donnait un petit
peu de sa personne pour tout le monde
[Musique]
c'est en 2002 que Bruno rencontre Nancy
à la caserne des pompiers le coup de
foudre est immédiat le couple se marie
peu de temps après et achète une ferme
qu'il va entièrement rénover
il s'appelle chouchou et petit cœur
Bruno dorlotte sa femme adorée se
souvient Anne-Marie Libert la grande
sœur de Bruno qui était très proche du
couple
ça avait l'air d'aller très bien moi
j'ai toujours vu Bruno qui a toujours
fait de les caprices de Nancy chaque
fois qu'elle ouvrait la bouche qu'elle
voulait quelque chose elle l'avait après
c'est tout elle voulait des chevaux elle
a eu des chevaux ils ont voulu des
années elle a eu des ânes elle a voulu
une autre voiture elle a eu saute de
voiture elle avait tout
ils vont avoir trois enfants deux
garçons et une fille il est aux anges
et la veine joie de vivre en lui
toujours le sourire j'ai des tas de
souvenirs comme ça de lui
était taquet malgré tout un pinceau rire
comme on dit on ne savait pas si blaguer
ou s'il était sérieux
il était génial
mais en 2013 un drame bouleverse la
famille Bruno pense avoir un cancer il
s'affaiblit de moins en moins et deux
ans plus tard le 11 mars 2015 il meurt
dans son salon terrassé par une crise
cardiaque
[Musique]
dans un village à côté de fosseurs nous
avons retrouvé des amis très proches du
couple
traumatisé ils ne veulent plus témoigner
nous les filmons en caméra discrète il
se souviennent très bien du soir de la
mort de Bruno Nancy les a appelé très
calme
et c'est tout ce que j'ai eu droit
les amis se précipitent alors à la faire
et nous qu'on est arrivé je dis c'est
quoi ce bordel il était assez
ouvert la bouche ouverte il était tout
seul dans le salon et tout le monde dans
la cuisine on est arrivé là
pas pas de médecin
c'est la première chose qu'on fait
Nancy n'a pas appelé les secours mais
Fabienne sa voisine est confidente est
là les amis de Bruno finissent par
appeler le SAMU trop tard
étrange attitude de la part de Nancy son
comportement futur le sera encore plus
à Verviers la grande ville du coin nous
avons rendez-vous avec Victoria marche
la journaliste au quotidien local la
Meuse pour elle la veuve était un peu
trop joyeuse
elle a toujours donné l'image d'une
femme qui aimait bien s'amuser qui était
jovial qui aimait bien sortir mais bon
quand son mari est mort ben voilà elle
s'en est donnée à cœur joie elle l'avait
pas l'air d'une veuve et pleurer disons
que il semblerait que le jour de
l'enterrement elle essayait de vendre la
voiture de Bruno
ça a été un peu vite et puis elle a
raconté à des copains que qu'elle était
tombée amoureuse le jour de son
enterrement aussi d'ailleurs elle avait
prévu de se marier au mois de septembre
donc
six mois après
le décès de son épouse ce qui est fait
un peu un peu vite quoi donc c'est vrai
que elle avait pas l'air
particulièrement affecté par par le
décès de son époux
dans le petit village de fosses on
n'apprécie pas du tout le comportement
de Nancy chacun y va de sa petite
anecdote
comme ce voisin qui a surpris la veuve
en train de faire un feu derrière la
ferme quelques jours après la mort de
Bruno
elle m'avait dit ces interactions je ne
me souviens à lui donc
[Applaudissements]
comme si il n'existe pas à venir
les premiers doutes surgissent
pourquoi Nancy a-t-elle si insouciante
que faisait sa voisine Fabienne à la
ferme le soir de la disparition de Bruno
la mort devient suspecte les amis de
Bruno sont persuadés que non s'il a tué
il décide de jouer les détectives
amateurs
[Applaudissements]
pendant trois semaines cet ami va
enregistrer Nancy avec son téléphone
portable à son insu elle oriente les
conversations pour que la veuve se
trahisse et un jour l'ami évoque la
voyante que consulte Nancy une certaine
Silvana nous avons pu nous procurer ce
document
[Musique]
elle a dit quoi
il m'a dit non
tu as fait ce coup de ressources
tu as fait ce que tu devais faire c'est
à dire tu es Bruno
sa sœur confie en tout cas
l'enregistrement à la police et une
enquête est aussitôt ouverte en juillet
dernier le corps est exhumé et une
autopsie effectuée à la demande de
Christine villewerth la procureur du roi
de Verviers
dès lors le parquet décide de faire
procéder à l'analyse des prélèvements
qui avaient été opérés et le sait tout
les résultats arrivent le sang contient
des doses létales largement létales de
strict mines le dossier est mis à
l'instruction et à ce moment-là
véritablement la machine judiciaire
s'enclenche
la strict nine de la mort aura Bruno
aurait donc été tué et stupeur les
médecins légistes se rendent compte
qu'il a été empoisonnés pendant deux ans
il y a préméditation c'est un assassinat
Nancy est arrêté et elle serait passée
aux aveux
que s'est-il passé depuis 2013 elle
aurait mis régulièrement de la mort aura
dans les plats de son mari mais il
dépérit sans mourir
alors ce soir du 11 mars 2015 Nancy
aurait mis une dose massive de strict
mines dans le yaourt de Bruno
il meurt quelques instants plus tard
dans d'intenses douleurs
[Musique]
pour mettre molders pierre l'avocat de
la sœur de Bruno liberty et
machiavélique
il faut se rendre compte de l'état
d'esprit et de la détermination qu'il
faut à cette femme pour pendant près de
deux ans empoisonné un petit feu son
mari et vivre à côté d'un mort en sursis
c'est absolument incroyable et
absolument sidérant pour finalement
donner la dose suffisante pour arriver
au décès mais cette période de deux ans
lui permettait évidemment de préparer en
réalité son alibi puisque ça lui
permettait de dire mais regardez ça fait
des années qu'il est malade
durant les interrogatoires Nancy finit
par impliquer sa voisine la fameuse
Fabienne
une cinquantenaire un peu naïve qui
était à la fois sa femme de ménage sa
nounou sa confidence elle aurait avoué
avoir fourni le poison mortel
il me semble que la voisine a
essentiellement contribué
au crime
par amitié pour aider son ami l'épouse
fait état d'un climat
délétère d'un climat de violence au sein
du couple qui l'a amené à cet acte
criminel
[Musique]
les avocats des deux suspectes ont
refusé de nous recevoir mais le conseil
de la sœur de Bruno lui récuse ce mobile
il estime que c'est plutôt l'appât du
gain qui aurait motivé l'assassinat
financièrement le décès lui a permis
d'abord de récupérer certaines
assurances vie on parle de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers d'euros elle est
hérite également des biens de son mari
puisque on parle de la maison de toute
une série d'autres biens il y a aussi
une collection d'armes cela peut prêter
à sourire mais absolument pas puisque
c'est une collection d'armes qui
s'évalue également à une trentaine de
milliers d'euros et qui a été d'ailleurs
vendu quelques jours après les faits
les deux femmes sont actuellement
incarcérées ici à la maison d'arrêt de
Lantin leur procès devraient avoir lieu
à la fin de l'année à Liège elle risque
la prison à perpétuité les trois enfants
du couple ont été confiés à la sœur de
Nancy
ils ont un rendez-vous macabre
aujourd'hui a lieu la reconstitution
judiciaire du meurtre d'un homme très
apprécié dans le village Bruno libert
[Musique]
témoigné nous les filmons en caméra
discrète
il se souviennent très bien du soir de
la mort de Bruno Nancy les a appelés
très calme
et c'est tout ce que j'ai eu droit
les amis se précipitent alors à la ferme
et nous qu'on est arrivé je dis c'est
quoi ce bordel il était assez
ouverts la bouche ouverte il était tout
seul dans le salon et tout le monde dans
la cuisine on est arrivé là
c'est la première chose qu'on fait
Nancy n'a pas appelé les secours mais
Fabienne sa voisine est confidente est
là les amis de Bruno finissent par
appeler le SAMU trop tard
étrange attitude de la part de Nancy son
comportement futur le sera encore plus
à Verviers la grande ville du coin nous
avons rendez-vous avec Victoria marche
la journaliste au quotidien local la
Meuse pour elle la veuve était un peu
trop joyeuse
elle a toujours donné l'image d'une
femme qui aimait bien s'amuser qui était
jovial qui aimait bien sortir mais bon
quand ton mari est mort ben voilà elle
s'en est donnée à cœur joie elle l'avait
pas l'air d'une veuve éplorée disons que
il semblerait que le jour de
l'enterrement elle essayait de vendre la
voiture de Bruno
ça a été un peu vite et puis elle a
raconté à des copains que qu'elle était
tombée amoureuse le jour de son
enterrement aussi d'ailleurs elle avait
prévu de se marier au mois de septembre
donc
six mois après
le décès de son épouse qui est fait un
peu un peu vite quoi donc c'est vrai que
elle avait pas l'air particulièrement
affectée par par le décès de son époux
dans le petit village de fosses on
n'apprécie pas du tout le comportement
de Nancy chacun y va de sa petite
anecdote
comme ce voisin qui a surpris la veuve
en train de faire un feu derrière la
ferme quelques jours après la mort de
Bruno
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les premiers doutes surgissent
pourquoi Nancy a-t-elle si insouciante
que faisait sa voisine Fabienne à la
ferme le soir de la disparition de Bruno
la mort devient suspecte les amis de
Bruno sont persuadés que Nancy a tué il
décide de jouer les détectives amateurs
[Applaudissements]
pendant trois semaines cet ami va
enregistrer Nancy avec son téléphone
portable à son insu elle oriente les
conversations pour que la veuve se
trahisse et un jour l'ami évoque la
voyante que consulte Nancy une certaine
Sylvana nous avons pu nous procurer ce
document
[Musique]
elle a dit quoi
alors
tu as fait ce que tu ressens
[Musique]
que s'est-il passé depuis 2013 elle
aurait mis régulièrement de la mort au
rat dans les plats de son mari mais il
dépérit sans mourir
alors ce soir du 11 mars 2015 Nancy
aurait mis une dose massive de
strict-nine dans le yaourt de Bruno
il meurt quelques instants plus tard
dans d'intenses douleurs
pour mettre molders pierre l'avocat de
la sœur de Bruno Libert Nancy et
machiavélique
il faut se rendre compte de l'état
d'esprit et de la détermination qu'il
faut à cette femme pour pendant près de
deux ans empoisonné un petit feu son
mari et vivre à côté d'un mort en sursis
c'est absolument incroyable et
absolument sidérant pour finalement
donner la dose suffisante pour arriver
au décès mais cette période de deux ans
lui permettait évidemment de préparer en
réalité son alibi puisque ça lui
permettait de dire mais regardez ça fait
des années qu'il est malade durant les
interrogatoires Nancy finit par
impliquer sa voisine la fameuse Fabienne
une cinquantenaire un peu naïve qui
était à la fois sa femme de ménage sa
nounou sa confidence elle aurait avoué
avoir fourni le poison mortel
il me semble que la voisine